these superhero movies are so freaking
intense I'm always like how did they
make this but with Shazam I'm like how
did they ever get Zachary Levy to
actually quit goofing around the set
seems like it was straight chaos in all
the best ways so if you thought Zachary
Levy would be the mature adult mentor to
his kiddo co-stars like Jack Dylan
Grazer think again because he was
actually a bit of a bad influence on Set
Let's test it out Levy and Grazer would
spend the whole time joking around and
trying to trip each other up they were
gonna be the nicking my heart on that is
yes you're right if you watch through
the bloopers it's obvious Levy wasn't at
all a man pretending to be a kid in a
grown-up body this is a kid in a
grown-up body the summer only Shazam
I mean the scene's over at this point I
don't know why and honestly I like how
crafty the director David F Sandberg is
though this crazy Genie
all this his hysterical chaos as an
opportunity he took that food fight
during lunch energy and turned it into
film gold he just let them pretty much
improv as many lines as they wanted you
ready to go round up your buddies
I like Jack Nickerson all of a sudden
and Jared Leto might tell you that
acting is serious work but I think we
all know that acting is at its best when
the actors feel comfortable to play and
make it their own it's called the
Deadpool effect oh oh hello because I
just coined that phrase right now my
favorite moment in the film has to be
when Zachary Levy grabbed a giant Batman
toy and threw it at Mark Strong yelling
get him Batman well that was all Levy's
idea there were actually a ton of takes
of this too he threw a bunch of
different toys including a Barbie doll
well obviously the Batman joke was the
best one I'm Batman it's kind of
impressive that they managed to keep the
jokes flowing like this considering how
freaking cold it was and honestly from
what I hear there's only one real regret
they had about shooting Shazam and
that's shooting in Toronto during winter
have you ever been and it's seriously
freaking freezing
I want to demonstrate that they are set
in dangerously unlivable frigid
conditions like Antarctica Siberia or
Toronto after November they just use a
snow machine clearly that's a smart call
David F Sandberg was told that
eventually everyone would get used to it
and he made sure to tell us that was
some terrible advice I mean just look at
how thin Levy Shazam suit is do you see
a parka no they had to cover him in a
giant blanket between takes just to keep
him warm he said he had to take the
entire suit off just to go to the
bathroom but managed to go the entire
shoot without having to make the
costumers go through that with him now
that I know that they were filming
throughout the winter that makes a lot
of sense Zachary Levy evidently pitched
that Shazam 2 needed to be set in the
Bahamas and I definitely wouldn't mind
seeing Zachary Levy in a sunny tropical
setting for Shazam 2 of course I love my
life now don't get the wrong idea about
the cold Sandberg was dedicated to
making sure that his actors were
comfortable the man was actually so
dedicated that he tried out one of those
rigs they use for green screens that
make the actors like fly and spin around
like proper superheroes and evidently
they call them tuning fork Rigs and
these things basically look like the
kind of thing you'd see on a playground
but do not try one if you ever get the
chance
and according to Sandberg it's a lot
harder than it looks to pretend to fly
he said it really hurts to your core and
requires a lot of strength in your chest
no wonder every dude that plays Superman
has like eight pack abs and as tough as
this is evidently it was no challenge
for returning to DC villain Mark Strong
who was no stranger to this kind of
thing he spent two weeks training for
all his action sequences and jumped into
it with a terrifying amount of intensity
don't worry we'll cover just how
terrifying Mark Strong is I just gotta
tell you how silly Zachary Levy is first
and it's sillier than you think believe
me remember how I said that Levy was
basically a kid in an adult's body
pretty much every time the camera wasn't
running he was making silly faces at the
camera like I did in middle school
algebra he also spent the entire time
joking with the crew members constantly
making him crack up when they were
trying to work Zachary Levy is basically
like having a stand-up routine going 24
7 that's only paused when the camera
starts rolling most of the time it
didn't cause too much of a problem
except remember how much I love that
Batman joke where he throws the toy at
Mark Strong well evidently the first
time he did it the man straight up took
out a camera
to throw something at Mark Strong I
might miss too but honestly just out of
self-preservation okay okay so I'm being
pretty harsh on Mark Strong but he's
actually a super sweet guy directors
like Matthew Vaughn and Guy Richie love
working with him time and time and again
for a reason but there's also a reason
that he gets cast as a super villain
time and time and again as well that's
cause his face is terrifying seriously
you can tell that the silliness on set
went down quite a bit any time he was in
a scene though he's not the scariest
thing that was on set his magic time to
transfer your power to me it's all been
fun and games so far but it's time to
get serious there's an ugly side to
making films like Shazam a terrifying
world where danger is lurking behind
every single Corner that would be the
Shazam Prank Wars the true monster in
the prank wars seems to be Jack Dylan
Grazer as someone who got his big break
making the it films he was no stranger
to jump scares and the most common thing
they did behind the scenes was lurk in
wait for a victim and then jump out and
shock them of all the victims Levy was
the easiest to get Grazer said that the
man is just the most gullible person in
the world which makes sense now all
these pranks were just harmless fun
except one that went too far and
actually held up the production for
several hours the baby powder attack
yeah for real so in an interview with
co-star Asher Angel Grazer admitted to
screwing up his entire day of shooting
angel said he saw Grazer standing next
to him holding a full hand full of baby
powder right when he was about to be
done shooting for the day Grazer then
doused him with it and was shocked to
see that it got all over his wardrobe
Angel then had to go back to makeup and
costuming to get himself and his costume
cleaned up and this delayed him like two
hours from going home oops just ran and
he stood there like I did this it was
funny everyone knows the most important
part of playing a superhero in a film is
a complete professional Devotion to the
craft and the source material through
research of the comics and dedication to
the character on the page it's Noble
work of course everyone also knows that
the second most important part of
playing a superhero is getting that
Superhero bod it's crazy right and
apparently nobody told my boys act that
they have fake muscles in the suit
because he went next level for his
Shazam bod he had a full body routine
created for him to Jack him up to
superhero levels of of swole that and he
had to give up pretty much all his
favorite snacks in exchange for Bland
chicken and broccoli like five times a
day that would be harder for me than the
workout to be honest he told Michael
Rosenbaum on his podcast that he went
from around 200 pounds to over 220 in
just a few months like just gaze at his
sensitive hot guy doctor look from The
Marvelous Mrs maisel and then to his
Shazam look those are the Gaines we're
talking about here I think we need to
see his workout routine like one more
time it will never cease to amaze me
that the exacts at WB were like yeah we
could put all these people in a room
together again and get a sequel